PROFESSOR: All right.
Welcome back to 6.849.
Today we are going over
TreeMaker, folding polyhedra,
folding checkerboards,
and Origamizer.
Lots of stuff.
And can't fit
everything in today,
but we'll be doing more
Treemaker in some sense
from a more
practical perspective
in the very next lecture
video and next class,
with a guest
lecture by Jason Ku.
So today we have a
bunch of questions.
We'll start with TreeMaker.
So the first
question is, wow, you
can make all these crazy
things with the tree method.
Are they really uniaxial?
And the answer is yes.
And I think it's
probably easiest
to just go through
some examples.
These are all from Origami
Design Secrets, this book
by Robert Lang, which is on
the recommended reading list.
And I think there's even an
electronic copy available
through MIT Libraries.
So you can read it online or
there maybe one in the library.
There's two editions.
These figures are from
the first edition.
So here is a-- the goal is
to design "Scorpion varileg."
These are all
Robert Lang designs.
You come up with this
stick figure, your tree.
TreeMaker makes
this crease pattern.
You can also see the
rivers here and the disks.
And then you get this base.
And then it folds
into that scorpion.
So while the scorpion
doesn't look like it
has a single axis--
scorpion, maybe.
There's kind of an
axis down the center.
But it's not just this axis.
It branches, then
it branches again.
You can make a tree and
it's still uniaxial.
So uniaxial refers to
this axis in the base.
All the flaps are
attached to that one spot.
So in this picture,
it's vertical.
Usually in the-- when
we draw all the figures,
we think of it as the horizontal
plane, or horizontal line.
So we imagine this is the floor.
And then we have flaps
attached to the floor.
Something like this.
So in that sense, when
you flatten this base,
everything lies along this axis.
Even though, in terms
of branching structure,
you could have lots of branches.
So that's to clarify
what uniaxial means.
Maybe not the best term, but I
have a few more examples here.
This hat includes
a color reversal.
Some crazy stick figure.
And you get your pattern.
Here's a somewhat simpler want.
It makes a more three
dimensional horse.
This Alamo Stallion.
So you can go through,
and for each of these,
I've just reverse engineered
from this crease pattern what
the stick figure must be.
And you're going to
do this on PSET2,
which will be released
in a few minutes.
And so this uniaxial's to
contrast from something,
the kind of most famous
non-uniaxial or biaxial origami
bases, with Montroll's Dog
Base, which looks like this.
So it's very easy to turn
this into all sorts of dogs.
This is a wiener dog.
But you have kind of one
axis here and one axis here.
Which is different.
It's not the same kind of
branching tree structure.
Of course, you can make a dog
using uniaxial method as well,
but it's kind of a fun
counter example of the things
you might do.
So that's uniaxial.
Next question is, do people
use TreeMaker and/or Origamizer
in practice?
And the short answer is no.
I would say most origamists
don't use software
to design things.
But they use a lot of the
ideas in their own designs.
So in particular,
the tree method
of origami design, which
TreeMaker is implementing,
almost every advanced
origami designer uses.
Not everyone, but most of the
complicated-- most complex
origami that you see uses
the tree method at least
to get started.
Origamizer is much newer,
so it's not used as much.
Most of the cool designs--
I'll show you a bunch of both--
are by Tomohiro Tachi,
who invented Origamizer.
But I think it's still evolving.
And hopefully, these
more advanced techniques
will catch on with time.
And by now, you've seen lots
of examples of the tree method.
I'll show a few more from
Robert Lang's website.
This is a local delicacy.
And these are all
on langorigami.com,
on his website.
And we'll see even more
examples in the next class.
And Jason Ku is going to give
an overview of various artists.
And in some cases, they
publish crease patterns.
Not always.
This is not quite
the tree method.
So this example was
standard tree method.
You've got disks and rivers,
which aren't drawn here.
You get a crease pattern.
This could be done
directly from TreeMaker.
I don't know for
sure whether it was.
This pattern is not
done with TreeMaker
because it's not regular disks.
This is the box pleating version
of the tree method, which
there's another question about.
So we'll talk about that more.
But you see all the creases
here are horizontal, vertical,
or diagonal, 45 degrees.
That makes it a lot easier
to fold, a lot easier
to find reference points.
You see it falls
nicely on a grid.
But still, you get an
arbitrary tree structure.
I think I have another example.
This one also-- well, this
has 22 and 1/2 degree folds.
It's a little bit more general.
Also very non-stick figure-like
models, particularly.
It's obviously called
the "Fiddler Crab."
No, sorry.
I have the wrong title here.
I will fix that.
I forget this guy's name,
but if anyone remembers.
He wrote about the division
between scientists and people
who know literature
as two different types
of intellectuals
that know almost
nothing about each other.
At least in the early
1900s when he was writing.
And one more example.
This is based on
a 60 degree grid.
So all the creases, I think,
lie at 60 degrees to the axis,
or horizontal.
There might be some 30 degrees.
So I'll talk a little bit
about this alternate version
of the tree method that doesn't
just use arbitrary circles,
but tries to stay
on these nice grids.
Here's just one more example.
Jason Ku is the designer
of this model called "Pan."
and he'll be giving
the guest lecture.
So this is just one example.
But tons and tons of
advanced origami artists
use tree method
of origami design.
And you get some pretty cool
crease patterns from it.
But I think most people
do it by hand, usually
on a computer using some
drawing programs that
can compute intersections and
do things with high accuracy.
And then they draw these
pictures, then they fold them.
And then you get
your base and then
you shape it into the model.
So next I want to show you
some practical examples of
So there's a bunch on
Tomohiro Tachi's Flickr site.
This is one of the earliest.
This is just making a
negative curvature surface
that curves in both ways
like a saddle, called
a hyperbolic paraboloid.
We'll see more of
those in the future.
But this is folded from
one square of paper.
And there's tabs on the backside
that you don't see here.
Here he's making a
kind of 3D bell curve.
Here's a computer mouse.
Apparently the scroll
wheel works fine. [LAUGHS]
Doesn't support USB, though.
Only Bluetooth.
We've got a nice mask.
These are all-- you're
given a 3D model,
and you fold exactly
that 3D model.
This is a tetrapod.
So here it sort of shows
Tomohiro's background
in architecture.
If you haven't seen
tetrapods, they're
used to hold back the ocean
and things from-- or hold
from erosion and
things like that.
So usually made out of concrete.
But here you can make
them out of paper.
Here's a flat design.
So here the mesh, the
triangles were all in a plane.
And of course, you still get
the tabs on the backside.
But you make this
very exact leaf.
You can get the
triangulation edges
exactly where you
want them to express
these veins of the leaf.
Here's what it looks like to
fold one of these in practice.
It's not quite a
square of paper,
but it could be a square.
And this is actually
folded at CSAIL.
You might recognize
some of the furniture.
And so while
Tomohiro's folding, he
uses various devices--
paper clips and clips
and so on-- to hold it in shape.
Because until it's
completely collapsed,
it kind of want to open back up.
So it's kind of like having
a hundred hands at once.
But when he's done, he'll
take all of them off,
and you'll get-- so this,
I think, was about 10 hours
and you get your bunny.
Easy.
Or this is the one we
did a little bit later,
just last year.
This is a laser
cut sheet of steel.
And now, here we've
cut out bigger holes
so there aren't too many
accumulation of layers.
But essentially the same design.
Somewhat coarser
mesh of the bunny.
And you have to wear gloves,
otherwise you'll cut yourself.
So we're perforating the
metal at the creases.
And then also takes
about eight hours.
A lot harder to fold steel.
And in the end,
you get your bunny.
So in principle, out of
any sheet of material,
you can make any
3D shape you want.
That's the exciting thing.
So I think Origamizer
is really powerful.
Obviously, it's hard to fold.
You need to be pretty advanced.
But there's a lot of
potential for designing
very non-stick
figure-like models.
So that was TreeMaker and
Origamizer in practice.
So next question is
about this box pleating,
which is the horizontal,
vertical, and 45 degree
creases.
And TreeMaker, is there
some theory for this?
And indeed there is.
And we started working on
it, me, Marty, and Rob Lang,
I think during his
first visit here,
which was probably
2004 or something.
A long time ago.
And the best writeup
of it currently
is in Origami Design Secrets,
especially Second Edition.
So
It has a chapter on
basic tree theory,
a chapter on box
pleating in general.
This is sort of
classical box pleating.
But then there's a
chapter on mixing the two.
Uniaxial box pleating
and polygon packing.
These kind of go together.
So if you're interested
in this stuff,
you want to design something
the way that the experts do,
check out Origami
Design Secrets.
Or go to an origami
convention where
Rob was talking
about this stuff.
We are working on
this giant manuscript.
It's currently called
the Mathematics
of Origami Design, which
is, in particular, trying
to prove the tree
method always works.
And we'll generalize
to things like this.
But it's not finished, so we
don't have a complete proof
yet that it all works.
Everything seems fine, but it's
tedious to write it all down.
So still working on it.
But I thought I'd show you
an example of box pleating
uniaxial origami design
from Origami Design Secrets.
So this is sort of typical
tree method of origami design.
If you're not necessarily
using TreeMaker,
but you're doing it by
hand, you think about, OK.
Suppose I want to make this kind
of insect, this stick figure.
Maybe I realize, oh, it's
kind of centrally symmetric,
so I'd like to
make the left half
of the paper same
as the right half.
You can also express that
in the TreeMaker software.
And then you start
thinking about where
these leaves
correspond to disks.
Then you've got to have
the corresponding rivers
in between them.
So you might start with
this kind of layout,
and then you try to blow it up
until things can't be expanded
anymore and there's
lots of touching.
So that would be
the usual approach.
Then from that, you could
apply the tree method,
get the crease pattern.
With the box pleated version,
essentially, instead of disks,
you have squares.
And instead of rivers, you
have these orthogonal channels
of constant width.
And so I'll just wave my
hands and say that happens.
Now, you get these weird
things-- you get these gaps.
You tend to get more
gaps in this way.
But in this case, instead
of just having a square,
you can extend it out
to be a rectangle.
So these guys are
actually going to fill
in these holes like this.
And then from
this, you can start
constructing a crease pattern.
So you start with
these ridge creases.
And this is something
like a generalization.
It's actually something like a
straight skeleton, which we'll
be covering in a
couple of lectures
for a different purpose,
where it was originally
developed for origami purposes.
But these are just
lots to bisectors.
And you'll have to see
the general version later.
And then you start putting
in the hinge creases.
These are these green lines.
And they're
perpendicular to these.
These blue creases are
going to be the floor.
And so on, you fill it in.
Eventually you get your
complete crease pattern.
So in a nutshell,
that's how it works.
You tend to get tabs that are
a constant width like this.
Constant height, I guess.
And so, it's a
general technique.
It's a little bit much to
explain here, but read the book
if you want to see it.
And I would say it's probably
some of the most common.
There's a lot of
intuitive ways to do it,
and then a lot of the details
are worked out in that book.
But it's quite common to
design bases in this way,
because it's just so
much easier to fold them.
You don't have to construct
really weird angles.
A lot cleaner.
But a little bit less
efficient, because instead
of using a disk, which is
the minimum amount of paper
you need to make a flap,
you're using a square.
So you're wasting
those little corners.
But not that much
more inefficient.
Cool, so that was that method.
Next question I have is about
the triangulation algorithm,
which I didn't even
cover in lecture.
So this was you set up-- you
have your piece of paper.
And you assign each
leaf in this tree
to some point in
the piece of paper.
And you satisfy the
active path condition
so each of these distances
measured on the paper
should be greater than or
equal to the distance measured
on the tree, which is
the floor of the base.
Great.
And so if you happen to
have some equalities,
you draw in active paths.
But what if you don't have any?
Or you don't have enough?
The tree method in
its original form
only works when the active paths
decompose the piece of paper
into convex polygons.
This is what you'd
like to have happen.
Each of the faces here
is a convex polygon.
If that happens, great.
You can use the
universal molecule
and you get your folding.
If it doesn't happen,
you have to modify
your tree a little bit.
There are a couple ways to
do this in the TreeMaker.
You can modify
these edge lengths
and try to modify them
as little as possible
so that things touch.
But the easy way to
prove that something
is possible-- because remember,
if we add a little bit
to the base, we
get an extra flap.
That doesn't really hurt us.
At the end, we
can hide the flap.
Just fold it against other
flaps and just pretend
it wasn't there.
So as long as we can
add flaps in order
to make the active paths
decompose into convex polygons,
we're happy.
And in fact, what we prove is
that you can keep adding flaps
until you get into triangles.
And triangles are always convex.
And so they make us happy.
So we will end up adding a
bunch of flaps in our tree
in order to triangulate
with active paths.
And then in each
of these, we just
fill in a rabbit ear molecule.
So that's the goal.
Now let me tell you how the
triangulation actually works.
It was originally
described by Lang.
It's also in the
textbook for this class.
I'll try to give an
abbreviated version here.
It's a little bit technical,
but here's the idea.
So suppose-- all right.
So we've assigned some leaves.
And suppose we have some
region that's not convex.
It's not a triangle.
Has more than three sides.
Now, some of these edges
may come from active paths,
and some of them may be from
the boundary of the paper.
So maybe the paper is here.
So this edge is not active.
It's just the boundary
of this region
because it's the
boundary of the paper.
So there are two types of edges.
But there should be, I guess,
at least one active edge.
And there's at least
four edges total.
So what I'm going to do is look
at any of the active edges,
and I'm going to imagine-- OK.
So that active edge, this
is in the piece of paper.
But now I'm going to think
about it in the tree.
So the tree looks
like something.
We don't really know what.
Any active path here
corresponds to an active path
in the tree of exactly
the same length.
So maybe it's from
this leaf to this leaf.
So it corresponds
to-- use a color.
This guy corresponds
to this path.
And the sum of those lengths
should be equal to that length.
It isn't, obviously, but there's
a scale factor in between here.
Lambda.
OK.
So here's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to modify the tree
by adding a new leaf somewhere
off of this path.
OK, where?
For convenience, let's assume
that this path length here
is 1.
Then I'm going to measure
out some distance x here,
which will leave a different
distance, 1 minus x, here.
And then I'm going to make
this length, I guess, L.
And I'm going to call this
leaf L. Capital L. OK.
This is a modification
to a tree.
I can do it.
I can do it for any value
of x between 0 and 1.
And i can do it for any value
of L greater or equal to 0.
So what I'd like to
do is design the tree
so that this point ends
up in an interesting place
on the piece of paper.
In fact, I claim that no
matter where I draw L here,
capital L, as my desired place.
Now, what I'd really
like is for-- I
should give these guys names.
This is called U, or say, in
the notes, I call it V and W.
So here we have W
and V. What I would
like is for these two
paths to also be active.
Meaning the lengths here
match the lengths in the tree.
I claim that no matter
where I put L in the plane,
anywhere in the plane, I
can choose x and choose L
so that these two lengths
are exactly correct.
Do you believe me?
Not really.
How many people think
this is obvious?
Good.
A couple maybe.
Let me give you a quick sketch.
It's not that
interesting, so I just
want to do it very briefly.
If you let x be a free
parameter, but fix l,
little l, then what
this corresponds to
is, in fact, an ellipse with V
and W as foci of the ellipse.
Because you have to hold the
sum of these lengths fixed
if you fix-- if you let x vary,
this length plus this length
is always going to be
the same if you fix l.
And so this is called
the major axis,
the sum of these two lengths
is going to be like 1 plus 2l.
And so if I have a
point, basically, there's
some ellipse of the
appropriate size that
passes through L. That will
let me choose little l.
And then as I vary x, I
walk around the ellipse.
So I just choose the
appropriate value
of x that gets me the
desired point on the ellipse.
That's it.
The point is, the set of all
ellipses with these two foci
spans the entire plane.
So wherever you
want to put L, you
can make those two paths active.
OK, this is good, because
it makes a little triangle.
But of course, if I just add
an arbitrary triangle, not very
interesting.
The good thing is I'm free
to put L wherever I want.
I'd really like
to put L say here
and draw active paths like that.
Because then I'm kind of
decomposing my polygon
into triangles.
That's not always possible.
So let's just go
through the cases.
In all cases, we're going
to simplify a polygon,
make it have fewer sides.
And that's on the next page.
So the claim is-- well, the L.
There's sort of three cases.
Going to reorganize
this a little bit.
One thing that would be nice
is I can place L-- maybe
I'll draw another
version of this.
So I've got UV.
I'll draw the
active paths in red.
So we know UV is active.
We've got L. If I
could somehow place L
so that it's active with two
other points, two other leaves.
This is V and W. This
is U and this is T.
If I can do this, and the region
looks something like that,
then I'm happy.
I'm going to put L there
and add in these four edges.
And essentially, if you look at
any one of these regions that
remains, there's
a triangle here.
That's definitely OK.
These regions, each
of them will have
fewer edges than
the original region.
That's pretty easy
to prove, because you
have-- Because you're connecting
to these four vertices,
this region won't have
this vertex or this vertex.
So it has one added vertex and
two removed vertices at least,
W and T. So this
one will be smaller.
And this is symmetric
for all of them.
OK.
So this would be a good case.
So what I'm going to do
is try to move L around.
I'm going to start
very close to VW
and just start
moving off the edge.
Initially, nothing
else will be active
because it's basically
right on top of VW.
But as I move around, I might
get another active path.
OK.
Maybe this is Case 1A.
Before we get there, Case
1 is you get LU active.
Suppose you just to get
one additional active path.
The other case is, nothing
else becomes active.
So here's V, here's W. Here's
L. Here's U. So this is active,
active, active, active.
OK, what I'm going to
do in this situation is,
if I want to keep LU
active, I can actually
move L on a circle.
As long as L stays on this
circle, LU remains active.
OK?
So just move it
along the circle.
Now, there are
two possibilities.
It could be it becomes
active with something else.
Then I'm done.
Or it could be it doesn't, which
means it will hit the boundary.
So it will hit a boundary point.
So Case 1A-- so this is Case 1.
You can make something active.
When you move along
the circle, either you
make another thing active,
or you won't and you
hit the boundary.
Case 1B is you hit the boundary.
And then I claim
you're also happy.
So in that situation--
draw it one more time--
we've got L on the boundary.
And we've got some path
here, here, here, here.
These are all active.
So here's L. OK.
I claim again, each
of these regions
has fewer vertices than before.
Should be pretty obvious.
This one is emitting W
and this was U. Yeah.
It's emitting W
and it's emitting
whatever's down
here, if anything.
Yeah, I think it's
pretty obvious.
You've got to check
all the cases.
There's a few details here.
But it should be each of
these regions has strictly
fewer vertices
than it did before.
And so you're making progress.
If You started with all faces
having some number of edges,
each time you do one of
these steps, you decrease it.
OK, the last case, Case 2, is
you can't make anything active.
This can happen, for
example, if you're
in the corner of
the piece of paper
and you have an active path.
I guess that's a
little less exciting.
Maybe your piece of
paper is this shape.
Be a little bit weirder.
So this will work for any
convex piece of paper.
So it's not quite a triangle.
And you're moving L
around here and you just
can't get another active path.
You have no vertices around.
This is W, this is U-- sorry,
this is V. And in this case,
L can go anywhere here.
It's free.
In that case, I'm
going to put L on one
of the vertices of the paper.
So I get this active
and this active.
And then I've decomposed
that region into pieces by,
this is what we call a diagonal.
We're adding a vertex to
vertex edge in this polygon.
And that always
decreases the number
of sides in each
of the subregions.
So if I just keep doing this,
taking any region of size
larger than three,
I will eventually
reduce them all to
have size three.
So they'll all be triangles.
So that's the triangulation
algorithm in a nutshell.
You can look at the textbook if
you want to see it more detail,
but it's pretty simple.
This proves that
something is possible.
I don't think TreeMaker actually
implements this algorithm
specifically, but you can
kind of do it by hand.
So I have a little example here.
This is TreeMaker.
I drew this really weird tree.
We call it a caterpillar tree
because you would actually
use it to make caterpillars.
And if you just plug this into
TreeMaker with all the lengths
unit, it will give you
this error message.
I couldn't construct
all the polygons
because things
weren't tight enough.
And if you look carefully--
it's a little hard
to see these colors-- but
the light green edges,
those are the active paths.
And here-- so this was a
triangle and it was happy.
If you look at this green
polygon-- maybe actually
I'll draw with the tablet.
So this thing is
an active-- that's
a region bounded
by active paths.
And probably the top edge
is not an active path.
That's just a boundary.
But it's not convex.
And so you're unhappy.
And so I just kind of
eyeball this and say, OK.
Well, probably I should
add another leaf here
that would maybe add a disk
that will probably fill that in.
So you don't have
to be super-precise.
Here we had the
very carefully place
the disk to make things touch.
But because TreeMaker's
always just trying
to blow things up
and make them touch,
it's quite a bit
easier in practice.
You just say, OK.
I will add an extra leaf
here, like that, to my tree.
And then I hit Optimize,
and boom, it works.
In this case, I was lucky.
In general, I might
get a nonconvex region.
I'd guess where to add
another leaf, and it works.
You can adjust.
Did that leaf have
to be that bit,
or could I get away
with a smaller one?
But eventually, you
will get a base.
And if you want, you could
carefully monitor this proof
and actually always succeed.
But in practice, it's
usually not that hard.
Questions about that?
So that was the triangulation
method in a nutshell.
The next question is about
the universal molecule.
And we might spend some more
time on this next class.
But I thought we could
actually look at this example,
because it's got a bunch of
different universal molecules.
So I will continue to draw.
So let me pick, let's say,
this universal molecule here.
It's a quadrilateral.
All right.
So those are four active
paths in this case.
And it corresponds to some tree.
So I don't have
handy here, but it's
going to be a tree
with four edges.
With four leaves, sorry.
Tree with four leaves is going
to look something like this.
This is a piece of
the bigger tree, which
you recall looked
something like this.
And we added one somewhere.
But this particular
quadrilateral
is doing some particular
subtree on four leaves.
In particular, there
are four leaves here,
correspond to four leaves here.
I don't know which ones.
I don't really need to know.
TreeMaker keeps
track of it for me.
And I happen to know that
these four paths are active.
Meaning the lengths in the
plane here match exactly
the lengths as measured
along the tree.
So what I do to make
this work-- this
is basically the
floor of the molecule.
Those four paths will all
lie on the ground level.
What I'm trying to do is slice
higher and higher in the base
to see what happens
when I slice.
And if you think about it, as
you move up here, in the plane
this corresponds to moving
parallel to these edges.
So I'm shrinking this
polygon by parallel offsets.
So let me draw one
parallel offset.
Approximately parallel.
OK, after I shrink a little
bit, might look like that.
An interesting moment
in this case is here.
Let me draw this carefully.
It should go-- this
should go here.
Ooh.
Oops.
I'm going to start over.
This is actually
already drawn for us.
It's this guy.
OK, this is a parallel offset.
And in this case,
something interesting
happens, which is this path.
So it turns out this
middle edge, in this case,
becomes active.
So what that means
is, originally,
if you looked at these two
points, these two leaves,
they had the wrong length.
OK?
So that's going to correspond
to something like these two
leaves.
They're opposite
corners of the quad.
And you measure the length along
the tree, you get something.
And the claim was, in the
plane, it was too big.
Now, as you do this
parallel offset,
as you shrink the
polygon, at some point
it will be just
the right length.
This could happen.
Doesn't have to happen.
If it happens, you have to stop.
Because if you kept going,
it would become too short.
And we know every
length here must
be greater than or equal
to length over here.
So when it becomes
equal, we have to stop,
and we have to
make this a crease.
Making it a crease
basically says,
ah, this is exactly
the right length.
I have to split here.
And where'd my chalk go?
And I have to sort of grow
now two different flaps
from that point.
The crease sort of
makes it horizontal.
And then we end up shrinking
in two different parts.
We shrink in this triangle,
which gives us a rabbit ear.
And we shrink up there
in that triangle.
Gives us another rabbit ear.
So it will end up giving
these angular bisectors.
In general, as you
do the shrinking,
you watch where the vertices go.
Those are your ridge creases.
So this one went along
an angular bisector.
That one did as well.
But once we do this
split operation,
because of this newly
active path, which we also
called a gusset in the
universal molecule,
then these vertices actually
split and go in two directions.
One for this thing
angular bisector and one
for that angular bisector.
So in general, for a
universal molecule,
there, are two things
that can happen.
You can be shrinking
your polygon
and suddenly discover
there's a newly active path.
And then you have to
divide it into two polygons
and start shrinking
those separately.
Or vertices can disappear.
So it could be you're
just shrinking, shrinking,
shrinking merrily along the way.
And then suddenly,
these two vertices
collide with each other.
So you get to
ridge creases here.
In this case, you just treat
those two vertices now as one.
So you'll start
shrinking like this.
And so these vertices will
now start going that way.
So in general, as
you're shrinking,
these are the only two types
of events that can happen.
Either two vertices merge, or
you get a new diagonal here
that becomes active.
When that happens,
you just divide.
Now, this will work
for any convex polygon
and you get your molecule.
It's hard to just
draw a picture of this
without using a
computer tool or really
keeping track of
what you're doing.
Because how do you tell when
something becomes active?
You have to look at your tree.
You have to measure lengths.
It's tricky to do
without a computer tool.
And that's why
TreeMaker was made.
But it can be done.
Probably even easier
with physical paper
if you know exactly what
lengths you're trying to match.
So that was a quick overview
of how universal molecule works
in more detail.
Next, I want to talk about a
few different open problems.
So one of them was-- these are
called gift wrapping problems.
So we have things like given
a square, a unit square,
let's say, what's the largest
regular tetrahedron you
can wrap?
That's still open.
All these problems are still
open except for the squared
to a cube which talked
about in lecture.
And I realize equilateral
triangle to tetrahedron.
That's also really easy.
If you can do it without
any paper wasted,
just clearly optimal.
But it would be very
cool to study these.
I think these would make a
good project or open problem
for the open problem session.
Folding a given rectangle with
given aspect ratio into a cube.
Also open.
Pretty much any version
you can think of
is open except the ones
that we've already seen.
Also wanted to mention for
checkerboards, a fun problem,
kind of in this
spirit, is, what would
be the best way to fold a
two by two checkerboard?
Even for a two by
two, we have no idea
how to argue any
kind of lower bound
about how bad you must do.
That you can't just take a
square and fold a two by two
checkerboard of the same size.
Surely you can't do that.
But we don't know
how to prove that.
So it would be a nice target.
We obviously have upper bounds.
We have constructions that
make two by two checkerboards.
I think from a 3 by 3
grid, you can make a two
by two checkerboard.
But is that optimal?
We have no idea.
So a couple questions about
the checkerboard folding.
So we had this
picture of how you
would take a square
root of paper-- you
start with a square paper.
You fold into this shape
with these long slits.
And then these guys fold over.
And then there are also
tab sticking up here,
which are not drawn.
And they fall over and give
you the color reversal.
Question was, how do you
actually build this thing?
This does not look uniaxial.
And indeed, we do not use
uniaxial techniques for this.
We use a separate
set of gadgets which
are kind of based on pleating.
And this will actually be
very similar to something
we see in a couple
of lectures when
we do box pleating to
make cubes and stuff.
But you just compose
these gadgets.
So this is kind of a
general tab gadget.
You collapse this
crease pattern,
and do a couple more folds.
And you end up with this
tab sticking out here,
and you can flip it up or down.
And you see that it has these
pleats running off to the side.
This mountain valley,
mountain valley, and then
valley mountain,
valley mountain.
And so those have to go all
the way through the paper.
And they come into this
construction, which basically
lets you make a big
slit in the paper.
Or you can also turn a corner.
And so you just prove that
these gadgets compose.
I mean, it's pretty
that they compose.
You just have to analyze how
much of the paper you're using.
And it turns out
to be really good.
That a short version.
If you want to try it
out, fold some gadgets.
Fun project idea
from you guys is,
given an image, sample
at low resolution,
make it black and white.
And then come up with
the crease pattern
that would fold, by this
checkerboard technique,
into exactly that two
color pixel pattern.
You could make all
sorts of useful things
like Space Invaders
and stuff like that.
You'd never want to
fold them, I think--
although maybe with low enough
resolution you could fold them.
But I think they'd be cool
just as crease patterns
by themselves.
You input a different
pattern-- I'd like web applet.
You change the pixel pattern.
And boom, it gives you
the crease pattern.
I think this would
be a fun project
if you're into
implementing things.
It's essentially the
algorithm we already have,
but it needs to be just written
out in detail and coded up.
OK.
Here's what it looks like
to fold an eight by eight
checkerboard with this method.
These are all by Robert Lang.
So a lot of precreasing
along this huge grid.
I thinks it's roughly 48 by 48.
And then some tape
to hold things
shut, mostly for photographing.
And to collapse, now we're
down by a factor of two or so.
Now you can see the
slits in one direction.
I think the particular
method being used here only
has slits in one direction.
Oh, no.
Here we've got slits in the
vertical direction as well.
You could see the tabs
sticking out here.
They're going to fall down.
There's some more of the tabs.
Start folding over,
and boom, you've
got your eight by
eight checkerboard.
Robert Lang says, wow.
That was not one of the
easier things I've done.
And this is folded from
a 48 by 42 checkerboard.
In principle, this method can
go down to 36 plus epsilon
by 36 plus epsilon, but it gets
messier crease pattern-wise.
And 36 would be better than the
best known eight by eight board
if you want seamless.
Notice these are
seamless squares.
No crease lines through them.
This one's not
necessarily-- this is not
better than known techniques,
but it follows our algorithm.
And that's what the
crease pattern looks like.
Cool.
Next we go to Origamizer.
So as I mentioned
in lecture, there's
two versions of Origamizer.
There's the version that's
implemented in the software,
and there's a version that
we're proving is always correct.
These are different because
the version in the software
doesn't always work.
And it remains that way
because the software
version is more practical.
And also, the
theoretical version
is still a moving target.
We change it every few weeks
to fix part of the proof.
It's almost done, but
it's been almost done
for a couple of years.
So we're still working on it.
Tomohiro was just visiting
a couple weeks ago,
as I mentioned.
And we're closing in.
I actually have with me the
current draft of the paper.
And it's not nearly as long as
this one with the tree method,
but it's still growing
and working up,
making sure all the
details check out.
And the theoretical version
is kind of complicated,
so I thought, in particular,
given this question,
we'll talk about
the software version
because it's actually
a lot simpler.
Only catch is, it
doesn't always work.
And it's described
in this paper if you
want to read it, by Tomohiro,
about Origamizer 2010.
And I have a few
figures from that paper.
Well, this is still
from Tomohiro's Flickr.
So we had this example
where you wanted
to fold this
hyperbolic paraboloid.
And here's what the
crease pattern looks like.
It's actually pretty simple.
You've got these
white polygons, which
are polygons from the surface.
That's what you need to fold.
And the goal is to lay them
out on the piece of paper--
this square is the
piece of paper--
so that I can--
for example, I need
to bring this polygon
to touch this polygon.
This edge has to
touch this edge.
Wouldn't it be great
if I could just
fold the bisector
of those two edges,
and this would come
right onto here?
Sometimes that happens,
but for example,
if this polygon is way down
here, that won't happen.
It will fold over
and they won't align.
There's two issues.
First you have to get
the angles to match.
And also there's this
vertical shifting.
If you place the polygons
in the plane in a good way,
this will work.
You always get alignment.
And what Origamizer implements
is nonconvex optimization,
a constraint projection, to
make all of the edges work.
And sometimes that's possible.
It's actually
possible fairly often.
And that's when the
Origamizer software works.
If it's not possible,
you're screwed.
This particular
method won't work.
But when it's possible,
things are great.
So essentially, you have to
bring the edges together.
Then you also have to bring
the vertices together.
Like these four vertices
come together to a point.
And so you get two
kinds of gadgets,
which are the vertex tucking
molecule to bring vertices
together, and edge
tucking molecule
to bring two edges together.
Edge tucking molecule
is a single crease.
Trivial in this construction.
Vertex tucking molecule
is complicated.
And in general, what
happens is for these points,
we construct what's called
a Voronoi diagram, which
is essentially, for
each of these points,
if you grow a disk at equal
speeds around all of them,
and when the disks
meet, you stop them.
So then these two
disks will meet along
this perpendicular bisector.
And they'll keep growing until
they kind of all die out.
And you'll get this tree
structure, in general.
Those are your main creases.
You follow that structure
and you do some stuff.
Essentially, what happens when
you fold along this Voronoi
diagram, you also have to add in
these creases from the Voronoi
diagram to the points.
When you do that, you'll get a
kind of mushrooming structure
that has too much material.
If you set it up right, all the
angles of paper that you have
are larger than what you need
in the folded state, which
would look like this.
And so what you do are lots
of little pleats to reduce
the angle. .
If you've got a
big angle of paper,
you can do a
mountain and a valley
and make it a smaller angle.
And that's what all
these creases are doing.
You've got these pleats
to reduce the angle here,
reduce the amount of material
here and here in order
to match the 3D structure.
So overall, what
the algorithm does
is first, given the
surface, it constructs
a suitable 3D structure of
where to put all the extra tabs.
Then it designs things so
that the angles are bigger
here than what they
need to be there.
This is, again, a
constraint projection.
Also constrains these
edges to meet up perfectly.
And then it just applies
all these crimps--
it's easier in a computer
than to see it here--
to make all the angles
correct to match the 3D model.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: So on
the sheet metal one
that you showed,
do you just cut out
the vertex shrinking
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So for the sheet metal bunny,
we just cut out these polygons.
Because otherwise, it's a mess
and you get lots of layers.
And the point was to make
it of one sheet of material,
but not necessarily a square.
So if you have really
thick material,
recommend cutting those out.
And we were laser cutting
to score the lines anyway,
so why not cut out
some holes as well.
Yeah.
So that way, you just have
edge tucking molecules,
which are really easy.
Mountain, valley, mountain.
And so it actually
is pretty practical
to fold these things out of
generalized sheets with holes.
So the non-software
version of Origamizer
works the same way, except
it does the full generality
of constructing this tuck
proxy, where the tabs should go.
And that can get very
messy in general.
It's just tedious to explain.
There are all these
crazy spherical diagrams
that you saw in lecture.
But it's not that exciting.
The more interesting part is
that the edge tucking molecules
can't just be a
single crease anymore.
They have to, in general,
kind of follow some path
to get to where they need to go.
But it's similar.
You just do a bunch
of different folds.
You can sweep them
one way or the other
in order to navigate this edge
to be where it needs to be.
So again you place the
faces in the plane.
In the mathematical
version, you can place them
anywhere you want.
It doesn't matter.
And then you have to
shrink them until they're
small enough that things work.
Then you route these paths
to get from each edge
to each corresponding edge.
The edge tucking molecules
are fairly straightforward.
The vertex tucking molecules
become even messier.
We still use a Voronoi
diagram in the end.
It's just there's
a lot more points.
Here we're just using the
corners of the triangles
as the source points
for growing stuff.
In the general case,
you have to add
lots of points in
the middle too.
But it turns out not to matter.
You could throw
in tons of points.
You could always fold
a Voronoi diagram.
You get this mushroomy thing.
And then you can just fold
away the parts you don't need.
You have to make
them really small
in order to make these
tabs not too big,
because if the tabs are too big,
they collide with each other.
That already happened
in the software version.
Even in the software
version, this
might not work because
this tab may be huge.
But you can-- in this case,
you just add a few more
and make this pleat up and down,
and you'll avoid collision.
So that was a quick, but
a little bit more clear,
overview of Origamizer
and how it works.
Any more questions?
Cool.
That's it for today.